we received an update there have now  been 18 bodies pulled from the collapsed  condo building in florida at least 140  some others are still  missing nearly a week after the disaster  crews are using search dogs electric  saws sonar equipment  they're methodically sifting through the  twisted metal and debris  adding to the danger storms which could  develop  in the next week if  a system does develop i want to ensure  you we have contingency plans  back up plans of how we will continue to  respond here  while responding to the hurricane  the former building inspector who said  the tower appeared to be  quote in very good shape in 2018 is on a  leave of absence from his current job  officials have promised to convene a  grand jury to investigate and examine  ways to safeguard residents in the  future